overwatch 2 is consuming overwatch one
bunny hopping is getting nerfed in apex
legends mobile and more
get ready to kiss overwatch one goodbye
during a reddit ama overwatch 2 director
aaron keller confirmed quote when
overwatch 2 launches on october 4th it
will be a replacement for the current
live service according to blizzard this
is to keep the player base unified and
as for players that can't let go of the
pass and try to play overwatch one after
october 4th they'll be asked to update
to the sequel instead for more on
overwatch 2 make sure you watch our big
interview with aaron keller where he
talks about more of what you can expect
from the sequel in other character
shooter news it looks like bunny hopping
won't be a viable strategy in apex
legends mobile going forward money
hopping is a technique that can be
pulled off in many first-person shooters
where players rely on momentum crouching
and repeated small jumps to move around
it's a very popular technique in
titanfall 2 allowing pilots to move
around the map more quickly than just
sprinting and making them smaller
targets that are harder to hit in
respawn's mobile battle royale being
able to successfully pull off the
technique can make you extremely
difficult to hit which has created
frustration in the community so it's
good to see respawn finally addressing
it the change will be made in the game's
next update and speaking of updates
let's switch gears to some xbox news as
it's been hinted at before xbox cloud
streaming will add mouse and keyboard
support to its streaming service the
long-anticipated feature was revealed
during a developer focused talk
delivered by morgan brown a software
engineer at xbox during the presentation
brown outlined how the xbox cloud gaming
team plans to reduce latency and assist
developers in optimizing their game's
resolution and graphics for streaming he
clarified that mouse and keyboard
support for xbox cloud gaming is coming
and that developers should work on
adding it to their games xbox cloud
gaming supports xbox games specifically
so you can't use the service to play pc
games or pc versions of games on your
phone or computer this feature will
allow players to play on the cloud from
their laptop or computer without an
additional peripheral no details as to
when this feature will arrive though the
encouragement of developers to add
support to their games indicates that it
might come soon and now let's talk about
something i'm very excited for a
playtell requiem because focus
entertainment has revealed it will
launch on october 18th for pc ps5
nintendo switch and xbox series xns in
an extended gameplay trailer focus
entertainment showed off more of the
game and it looks even more cinematic
than its predecessor it shows the
protagonist amicia and her little
brother hugo trying to escape enemies
while she fights them off with hugo now
being able to control his powers he
helps emesia out by revealing enemy
locations which is the game's x-ray
vision mechanic amisia now also has more
lethal ways of disposing of her enemies
including using her dagger in crossbow
my level of excitement for this game is
out of 10 but let me know where you sit
on the scale and i'll see you tomorrow